après plusieurs mois d'écriture et
d'entraînement ces élèves de seconde du
lycée de villa roi partage aujourd'hui
leur création dans le cadre du parcours
d'éducation artistique et culturelle un
projet qui a démarré en septembre
dernier
le but est de partager la poésie celle
qu'on lit celle qu'on apprend et celle
qu'on écrit soi même en étant dans les
traces des poètes qu'on étudie et en
suivant les traces d'un poète bien
vivant impôts est bien vivant qui se
nomme il gaudin les élèves ont pu le
rencontrer à plusieurs reprises lors
d'ateliers au début ce n'était pas trop
chaud parce que c'est pas trop mon truc
les poètes tous à l'arrêt comme c'était
yves godin après on a appris à le
connaître et tout et j'ai bien minime et
boum boum pour les aider à prendre
confiance en tout l'environnement qui
était qui était avec eux que ce soit
l'espace des gens qui nous a permis à
chacun - y compris de nous libérer de
plein de préjugés et donc d'avoir de
l'à-propos poétique
une approche qui a conquis les jeunes
poètes yvon godin le personnage on a
bien aimé une amie tout à l'aise et j'ai
l'impression nous a plus aidé à être à
l'aise comme ont récité le poème et il
nous a beaucoup aidés sur l'écriture
aussi
moi ça m'a plu du coup j'ai pris mon
stylo ma plume et j'ai commencé à
rédiger
je pensais pas que moi je pouvais écrire
quelque chose moi c'était réservé aux
grands poètes la trentaine de poèmes
écrits par cette classe de seconde sera
prochainement éditée dans un recueil
intitulé les dormeurs du bal